follow new federal rules that allow
women to get medication prescribed by
their doctor from a certified Pharmacy
imagine
so today
we are fighting back
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm pleased to announce that President
Biden I'm announcing it today has issued
a presidential memorandum on this issue
members of our cabinet and our
Administration are now directed as of
the president's order to identify
barriers to access
to prescription medication and to
recommend actions to make sure that
doctors can legally prescribed that
pharmacies can dispense and that women
can secure safe and effective medication
President Biden has done that at the
same time that we work to protect this
aspect of reproductive care
many states have gone even further and
now have total bans in effect
Alabama
Missouri and South Dakota just to name a
few
and as as clinics close in those States
understand as clinics are closing in
those States patients have lost access
to other basic care
such as routine checkups
cancer screenings
and contraception
and to everyone listening be sure no one
is immune from these impacts
even in states that protect Reproductive
Rights like New Jersey Illinois Oregon
even then people live in fear of what
might be next
because
republicans in Congress
are now calling for a nationwide
abortion ban
[Applause]
some even from the moment of conception
[Music]
the right of every woman in every state
in this country to make decisions about
her own body is on the line
and I've said it before and I will say
it again how dare they
[Applause]
and you know there's a collection of
words
there's a collection of words
that mean everything to us as Americans
the heartfelt words of our great
national anthem
that America is the land of the free
and the home of the brave
but let us ask
can we truly be free
if a woman cannot make decisions about
her own body
[Applause]
can we truly be free
if a doctor cannot care for her patients
if families cannot make intimate
decisions about the course of their own
lives
[Applause]
and can we truly be free
if so-called leaders claim to be quote I
quote on the Vanguard of freedom
while they dare to restrict the rights
of the American people and attack the
very foundations of freedom
[Applause]
understand clearly the majority of
Americans
the majority of Americans oppose these
attacks
Americans of every background in every
Community have voiced their perspective
from Kansas to California Michigan
Montana Kentucky and Vermont they spoke
with their vote
in essence they said
one does not have to abandon their faith
or deeply held beliefs
to agree that the government should not
be telling people what to do with their
own bodies
so know this
President Biden and I agree and we will
never back down
we will not back down
and we know
we know this fight will not be won until
we secure this right for every American
Congress must pass a bill that protects
freedom and liberty
the bill that protects Reproductive
Rights and President Biden will sign it
[Applause]
so yes
America is a promise
a promise we must all make real
in every state
in every community
in every state house
in every doctor's office and yes in
every election
so
to all the friends and leaders I say let
us not be tired or discouraged
because we're on the right side of
History
so we will continue to stand together in
the fight to protect the freedom and
liberty of all people of all women
everywhere and here now
on this 50th anniversary
let us resolve to make history and
secure this right
[Music]
today I invite all Americans to join us
and to remember
when we fight
we win thank you all may God bless you
and may God bless America thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you